all right guys
bang bang let's go
i'm gonna wait a couple minutes to get
some people in here but i want to spend
time
today talking about the current economic
recession
that we are in why it is likely to get
worse before it gets better and then
what the impact on various companies are
and also how that may change things that
you are thinking about doing
before i forget for those that are
watching this after the live
please like the video leave a comment
and subscribe
to the channel all right we're starting
to get some people in here
hello hello hello so essentially let's
just start
with where are we right if we go back to
kind of pre-pandemic we were sitting at
one of the strongest economies in
history
we had seen record growth in company
values
we had seen record profits we had seen
incredible rise over the last decade
plus coming out of the 2008 2009
financial crisis and then on top of all
of that
we had record low unemployment we were
sitting about 3.5
unemployment in february and everything
looked like it was going to go up and to
the right
forever we were going to end up having
you know trillions and trillions of
dollars of gdp and
everything was gonna be awesome and then
the pandemic hit
and when the pandemic hit there was two
key factors that occurred
the first was it killed people and of
course because of the health crisis
there had to be a reaction that reaction
was
to essentially shut down economies and
what we did was we sent everyone home
so people will debate the merits of
should we have done that should we not i
frankly don't care
it happened and when you grind an
economy to a halt like that
what you end up seeing is that
businesses can't operate you
government mandated shutdowns right
there's unemployment that skyrockets and
so the
impact of this decision to send everyone
home is government mandated shutdown
was that we saw over 40 million
americans
lose their jobs in about a 12 to 16 week
span so three to four months we saw
40 million americans lose their job to
go back
as a refresher in 1929
which is the start of the great
depression there was
3.1 unemployment record low and that
unemployment jumped from 3.1
to over 8.5 percent to then over 15
in the next two years and so what you
end up seeing is
we have accelerated faster on the
unemployment track
than even in the great depression right
it only took us a couple of months took
two years to get to 15 plus percent
we pretty much got there in about a
matter of four months uh during this
recession
and so as soon as you saw businesses
being shut down in terms of being told
to go home
40 plus million americans right there
was that that one big week back in uh
march where
six million people filed for
unemployment claims the highest ever
before that was about seven hundred
eight hundred thousand back in 1982.
so all of a sudden we saw this
record-breaking unemployment number two
weeks in a row remember there were 6.6
million unemployed 6.6 million
unemployed
uh in back-to-back weeks the government
the federal reserve said we have to step
in
and so when they stepped in what they
did was they created
a historic stimulus package they created
a monetary stimulus package
that ended up topping over two trillion
dollars right
the one of the packages was two trillion
dollars by itself then there was a bunch
of lending facilities and other things
that they did
and so what has occurred over the last
couple of months is pretty simple
we have seen a pandemic that caused an
economic crisis
which then led to massive response from
governments and central banks around the
world
now in the united states let's break
down what have they done to try to stop
or mitigate a lot of the damage
there's a lot of easy things like they
have uh
inflated asset prices by pumping
liquidity into the market right there's
a liquidity crisis everyone got nervous
and scared they wanted dollars they
started selling all their assets
the dollar got strong and all the asset
prices went down so when you pump
liquidity into the market
all of a sudden you're trying to
stabilize prices
stop them from falling right make it
easier for people to get dollars
and so they essentially did that and
they did it pretty well
and what i mean by that is they created
all sorts of lending facilities so if
you look at the repo markets
they started to buy corporate debt
government debt right they did
everything they possibly could to stuff
money into the system
well look at what has occurred well
after there was about a 30
drop in public stocks we have now seen
a massive rally including seeing their
nasdaq hit an all-time high again
right companies that have three and four
x in value
like the teslas of the world we've even
seen bankrupt companies that have
exploded in value in the public markets
and so obviously the mitigation or the
stoppage of
the sell-off in stocks occurred and then
we saw this massive rally
now along with what i will call the
stock market manipulation that has gone
on right you can debate the merits again
good or bad it happened we also realized
wait a second there's a lot of people
that are going to lose their jobs
there's a lot of small businesses that
are not in the public markets
that are going to need help as well and
so this is where a lot of these monetary
stimulus
uh efforts came in or this relief came
in and so
we started with individuals there was an
additional 600
per month on the unemployment front to
help people who are going to get on
unemployment so they're going to file
for unemployment insurance
they were going to get that insurance
plus an additional 600 a month
this created a situation where many
people were actually uh
making more money on unemployment than
they were off of unemployment back at
their jobs
now that's actually probably more of a
statement
in terms of we weren't paying employees
enough to begin with but that's what
occurred so there's 600
extra a month then what we said was
we're going to create the
paycheck protection program the ppp
loans
these are essentially very um low
interest rate loans
that could be forgiven if you follow
certain guidelines
uh part of those guidelines were you had
to be a small business or you had to
prove that you were affected by the
pandemic you then could take the loan
and then if you essentially in a very
over generalized manner if you promised
to not
fire your employees or to dock their
salaries
for a extended period of time let's call
it until october 1st
then you would not have to pay back the
loan right now there's nuances but
that's generally what happened
well a lot of people hundreds of
billions of dollars
was applied for and granted and people
received
uh the pvp loans these small businesses
received them we then also saw stimulus
checks go out
so i think was over 100 billion dollars
in stimulus
checks were sent directly to people so
this is up to twelve hundred dollars
a one-time cash injection uh to try to
help people kind of get over the hump
and if you remember
kind of infamously uh the treasury
secretary said 1200
should last i think he said it was like
three months or something crazy um
and so that was kind of the idea was
let's get liquidity directly in the
hands of the people
so you've got a beef up of unemployment
you've got the ppp loans and then you've
got direct stimulus checks on top of
those three measures we then saw
bailouts of specific industries so the
airline industry for example they
received about 50 billion dollars in
bailout money
that 50 billion dollars one-third of it
is uh
sent as a low-cost or low-interest loan
that has to be paid back two-thirds of
it was essentially free money
there was no equity in exchange for
there was no uh promise to pay it back
it was a grant of capital that said if
you do not fire your employees you guys
can just have this money
so all of that sounds great in the sense
of the government one realized that
there was a problem
two they immediately realized they were
gonna have to step in and intervene in
the markets
three they went back and looked at the
2008-2009 playbook and decided they were
going to use that playbook again
here and they actually moved pretty
quickly right for a government in a
matter of weeks
they were able to put together a
multi-trillion dollar
stimulus package and get it into the
market now we can all debate should they
have done it faster should there have
been better
optimization more nuance of course but
if you are going to do this
speed and kind of decisiveness is what
matters and
generally they did a good job so now all
of a sudden
we are four to five months later right
from kind of when the pandemic started
and what we see is a complete
dislocation in the market
between economic reality and
asset prices i'll give you two core
examples the first is obviously stocks
so we have stocks that are hitting
all-time highs they're exploding in
value
yet all of the underlying economic data
suggests that actually
gdp is down we are in a full-blown
recession we are seeing
businesses shut down we are seeing uh
record levels of unemployment
all of the economic data is bad but
stocks are up why
is that again there is artificial
intervention
and manipulation of stock prices you can
debate whether that's good or not that's
what's occurring in the market
the injection of liquidity into the
market is going to
devalue the dollar over some period of
time and it is going to
inflate asset prices right there is no
way
that a company's revenue drops 90 plus
percent
in let's say the movie theater industry
uh in some cases there was 80 90 percent
loss in
um revenue in the airline industry and
the cruise ships all this kind of stuff
right
there's no way that it drops 80 90
percent the stock drops
60 to 80 percent and then all of a
sudden it rallies again 50
up that just it doesn't match what the
economic reality is
and so that dislocation is very heavily
driven by the manipulation
and intervention by the government in
the market good or bad who cares that's
what's occurred
now the second place that we're seeing
an incredible dislocation between
economic reality and actually ask
the actual access prices is in the
residential home market in the united
states
so most people would think when there's
an economic crash or an economic
recession all of a sudden home prices
should drop significantly
and there should be no deals getting
done right if you see like a sam zell go
on television and say hey
in the commercial real estate market
there's no deals being done the
sellers are still attached to their
pre-pandemic prices
they believe their buildings are worth
what they thought they were worth back
in january and february
they have not yet accepted the fact that
the pandemic has changed the market
and therefore they're not coming down in
price the buyers are expecting a big
discount and so you don't have kind of a
a market there because there's a a
difference of opinion so no deals get
done
well in the residential market though
that's not what the what is occurring
instead the exact
opposite is occurring home prices are
going up
and we're seeing a plethora of activity
in
home sales why two things
one we are seeing incredible low-cost
cheap capital flooding residential homes
right
interest rates are been dropped to zero
in terms of the the
federal interest rate there and also
when you have access to
cheap capital what do people do they
strike they refinance their home they
try to go buy homes all that kind of
stuff
and so you have that trend going where
just cheap capital is flooding the
market and people don't think that that
cheap capital is going to go away
anytime soon
the second thing you have is people are
looking around and saying wait a second
why do i live in san francisco
why do i live in new york city i can go
and spend the same thing i spend on an
apartment
and go buy a three-bedroom nice home
with a yard somewhere else
and so you get a lot of um kind of
migration
out of major cities into these other
areas now that trend will likely
continue and actually accelerate over
time but we've already seen the start of
that
the combination with the cheap capital
uh you get is
lots of deals being done on top of that
many people don't know but the u.s
residential real estate market is
actually at a
deficit in terms of production every
year so if you look at how much demand
there is for
new home building or for purchasing of
homes and then you look at what the us
actually produces every year in terms of
new homes or onto the market
we produce a 200 000 to 250 000
home deficit every year meaning we don't
produce enough homes in order to satisfy
demand
on an annual basis so the stat that i
saw was 200 to 250 000 homes
is the equivalent of basically a city
like miami so
every year we produce at whatever number
of homes we produce
and then we need to actually produce an
entire city like miami's worth of homes
in order to satisfy demand and kind of
have a net uh
kind of have it net out without a
surplus or deficit because we don't do
that
that means that there is a deficit of
supply and if you have
increasing demand and supply can't keep
up naturally you're going to see
home prices rise so that's what we're
seeing is you see
um kind of anecdotally around the
country people are saying wait a second
i listed my home and i had six offers
for it
or i thought we were in a recession why
are there six offers well
one you have a deficit of home supply
two you've got cheap capital and three
you've got a lot of migration going on
and so the dislocation again there's 40
plus million americans that have lost
their job in the last couple of months
yet home prices are actually increasing
and the market
is um having incredible efficiency in
terms of getting deals done right you're
seeing
record level of home prices actually or
home
transactions occurring now couple that
also with
in the month of june we saw 17.5
plus percent increase in construction
where is that coming from well 17
increase in construction is actually a
misleading number so it's not so much
about is that a year-over-year number
that is a month-over-month number
meaning that a lot of
states actually shut down construction
in the months of
march april and may they started to come
back in may and then june we saw about
almost 20 percent
increase in construction that's simply
reopening we're still down year over
year on the on the construction side
but home prices continue to rise
transactions continue to go up
so we've got stocks and we've got home
uh residential homes
in the united states both of those are
trending as if we are living in good
times
yet the economic reality tells us we're
living in bad times
how does this end well here's where i
think a lot of people are not yet paying
attention
there's a ton of people who back in
march and april were freaking out
right they didn't know what happened the
uncertainty the fear the chaos
there was just this feeling of like oh
my god what's gonna happen the blood was
in the street if you will
stock prices sold off 30 gold was down
almost 15
bitcoin on one single day dropped 50
right everything froze no commercial
real estate deals being done residential
completely froze
all kinds of things happening in the
private um startup and technology world
deals immediately term sheets getting
pulled just absolute chaos and
uncertainty
well now we fast forward three or four
months everyone kind of feels
okay right not everyone feels great
obviously because there's still
a ton of unemployment gdp is down right
the virus is still there we're wearing
masks all that kind of stuff but the
stock market's up
home uh residential homes are getting uh
sold at record levels
so everyone's kind of saying wait a
second like maybe it's gonna be okay
but the thing is that we are riding the
high of the monetary stimulus so i
always give the example that
uh the u.s economy is like a crack
addict right and the crack addict
uh if you think about it at one point an
addict never had crack before
and they were living their life somebody
one day says to them hey you should try
some crack
and they try it and they get high and
they kind of like it and so a couple
days later they try it again
and this time they like it again and so
they do it again and again and again and
eventually
their body begins to get used to the
amount of crack that they're taking
right
it's a scientific kind of chemical
reaction in their brain
so now all of a sudden they're used to
the certain amount of crack that they
started taking
well then to get that same high that
they got originally they have to take
more
later on and then more and more and more
and eventually if they completely get
out of control and abuse it they
actually end up overdosing and dying
and so that's how a kind of the
evolution of a crack addict works
but they have to take more crack over
time to get the same high
the economy is no different if you go
back right
we've had to inject more monetary
stimulus
over time in order to get the same high
so in the 2008 2009 crisis
when we decided to step in and intervene
in the markets and kind of artificially
mitigate the economic damage and kick
the can down the road on the structural
issues
what we ended up doing was simply just
getting high on monetary stimulus
but it only took us hundreds of billions
of dollars
in at that time fast forward now you
know
10 12 years and now during this economic
recession
we have to do trillions of dollars in
order to get the same high
off the monetary stimulus so we are no
different than a crack addict who's
addicted to crack
we are simply addicted to monetary
stimulus which is fine
the problem though is just like a crack
addict's high eventually wears off
and then you have kind of coming off of
that high
that's what happens with monetary
stimulus as well so we saw in 2005
2016 and uh 15 17 in that range
we started to try to actually raise
interest rates and pull back and do some
quantitative tightening and stuff and we
got gyrations in the market
so we know that that's not really
something that the the economy is used
to
nor does it respond well to but also
what we know is in the short term
when we pump a ton of um liquidity into
the market
we then get ourselves in a situation
where at some point it runs out
so let's go back to the monetary
stimulus that we have that we announced
and have kind of implemented the last
couple of months
let's start with unemployment for
example that 600
extra the beefing up of unemployment
insurance per week for people
is set to end in july at the end of july
if that ends that means every single
person the millions of americans that
are unemployment right now
will start to make 600 less per month
some people will still be able to
survive
on whatever the traditional unemployment
insurance is some people will not
and so there is going to be a kind of
reckoning
in that market for people who are
unemployed and they're about to make
600 less a month if you go through the
math or 600
less a week if you go through the math
that's 2400 less a month that is a very
material difference in how much money
you are actually consuming
or pulling in as income now if you then
go and you say okay well that's
unemployment maybe we should open up the
businesses we should get people back to
their jobs
well we're also going to see all those
people who took ppp loans so the
airlines all those small businesses
everyone who took these loans that were
forgivable as long as you kept your
employees through
uh to october 1st well october 1st is
coming pretty fast
and so we already see people like the
airlines sending out
to tens of thousands of their employees
saying hey
we are likely to cut your job at the end
of september
so we are basically going to keep you on
until we hit
the kind of threshold that we need to to
make this loan forgivable
and then we're going to fire people and
it's not gonna be we're gonna fire a
hundred people or 500 or a thousand
people
there are certain airlines that are
sending this to 25 30
50 000 employees saying that hey you're
likely to lose your job
you should either quit the job now and
go find a different one you should take
early retirement
you should take involuntary or you take
voluntary leave all that kind of stuff
but when these pvp loans run out and if
the economy is not back to the point
where businesses have enough income to
actually support
their customer or their employee base
what are they going to do
they're going to fire the employees and
so we may get an entire second wave of
layoffs simply because the pvp money is
going to hit the threshold that they
needed to to actually
then make it forgivable so you've got
unemployment benefits that are going to
expire
you then have within kind of two months
of that you're then going to see all of
a sudden
uh another wave of layoffs from the pvp
money and you sit there and you say wait
a second
and there as of right now there's no
more stimulus money coming so what are
these people going to do well
we used artificial intervention in the
market and manipulation of the markets
in order to mitigate the damage a lot of
people are very happy that we did that
but what happens when it runs out and
that's what we're facing now
and so again you cannot have dislocation
between economic reality
and asset prices forever either the
asset prices have to come down
or the economic situation has to improve
now what the federal reserve and the us
government has
hoped would happen is that they could
inflate and kind of
mitigate the damage for long enough with
this intervention so that the economic
data
uh could bottom right so it would drop
it would bottom and then it would
recover
and by the time the effects of the
monetary stimulate into
kind of pre-pandemic levels well if you
look outside
there's a lot of states that all of a
sudden have re-closed
certain types of businesses they went
through all the shelter in place
they began reopening the virus cases
exploded
and then all of a sudden now they're
starting to reshut the bars the
restaurants all this kind of stuff
this doesn't appear like it is going to
go away anytime soon it may
but it doesn't appear like that's going
to happen and so we've got a second
perfect storm occurring
we have unemployment benefits expiring
we've got pvp money that is going to
allow people to start firing their
employees in the next couple of months
and then we have what looks like a
economy that is not going to reopen how
everyone thought it was going to reopen
and so it is likely that that economic
data is going to stay
bad or not ideal for a long period of
time right gdp
could still continue to be negative into
q3 and q4
if that occurs i don't think asset
prices can stay inflated forever
and so what you have to start to ask
yourself is
wait a minute let's zoom out for a
second we're only
four to five months into this economic
recession if you go back to 2008-2009 or
any recession
previous to that how many recessions
were only four months long
not very many right if at all any and so
people have this feeling that things are
going well everything is
being uh okay asset prices are starting
to rise
but don't be fooled don't get high on
the monetary stimulus supply
remember we are in an economic recession
we just saw a massive liquidity crisis
in which the fed decided to step in with
trillions of dollars and try to mitigate
but what it is doing is it's masking the
economic reality
and again they may be able to pull it
off right they may be able to pull off
the magic trick up
let's mask the economic reality let's
inflate asset prices it'll give it time
for the economy to come back
but if they cannot what actually ends up
happening is they may have caused more
damage
in the law in the medium term meaning
that that masking of the reality
simply saw stock shock 30 they then
explode asset prices and what if we get
a market correction in the future okay i
don't have a crystal ball
i don't know what's going to happen but
it's pretty clear that if the monetary
stimulus cannot last
long enough for the economy to recover
there would likely then be
a correction in the market that's in
homes
that's in stocks that's in every asset
class if that occurs
this would have been one of the most
incredible
dead cat bounces in the world because
and in history
because what we saw was such a
manipulation of asset prices
and so i think that people just have to
remember look at the underlying economic
data
we have to understand is that going to
recover
in time or is the monetary stimulus
going to wear off before that
now there is a variable here that could
change all this analysis
that variable is there could be more
economic stimulus or monetary stimulus
on the way
so if you look at both the democrats and
the republicans they all
want to create more monetary stimulus
they just can't decide and agree on
how they should do it so you see things
like donald trump saying
uh in his administration saying hey we
should send more stimulus directly to
the people and it should be more than
twelve hundred dollars
you see on the other side there's been
proposals from the democrats of three
plus trillion dollar stimulus packages
right you've seen people on both sides
of the aisle say hey maybe we should
actually extend those unemployment
benefits so they don't expire in
july maybe we should extend them to the
end of the year or maybe even into 2021.
we've seen people who said look the ppp
money maybe we should change some of the
um information there we've even seen
proposals for things like ubi where
people have come forward and said
we should just start giving people two
thousand dollars a month
right and just continue to do that until
we reach pre-pandemic levels of
economic output for our country now
again i don't know what's going to
happen but unless there is more stimulus
on the way
we are starting to see on the horizon
when some of the stimulus
effect will wear off unemployment end of
july
ppp end of september right you start to
see as we get closer
my guess is that there is going to be
more stimulus and when that occurs
i also believe that we now have uh
representatives
and a federal reserve on all sides of
the aisle so there's two parties and
there's a bunch of independents
they all are emboldened and the reason
why they are emboldened right now
is because they've seen that they can
quote get away with it
they did a two trillion dollar stimulus
package and have
zero concern about any sort of inflation
literally the federal reserve chairman
jerome uh jay powell went on
television and he said we're not even
worried about inflation right now
right when asked if he was going to move
interest rates he said we haven't even
thought about thinking about moving
interest rates up again
so this is something where they feel
like they've got commanded control
of managing an economy and they can do
all sorts of unprecedented
things in order to manipulate the
economy well we better hope that they're
right because if they do things
that don't work we're the ones who are
going to feel the pain and if you go as
far as to understand
okay if they start to do some of this
stuff remember what i said
um back in uh i think it was march or
april the unemployment for example
who's going to be the politician who
says i'm taking away your 600
extra a week uh unemployment benefits
especially in an election year i just
don't see that happening
i don't think that they can do that
either either political party
you're going to have again millions of
americans that you're going to take
money away from
it's political suicide and so i think
you're going to see the extension
somehow someway at the end of the month
i could be wrong but we'll see what
happens there
in terms of more stimulus checks there's
nothing
more powerful for a president who is up
for a re-election
than to send money directly to people in
their bank account
right this is the whole idea of trump
box there is a literally a
political incentive to do it so i think
that we will see some sort of package
get put together
uh in q3 and go ahead and go out and so
it's hard for me to see
a pathway to an economy where the
economic data
reigns supreme over the manipulation of
the assets
in an election year right it is probably
one of the things that the
incumbent political party can hang their
hat on is if they can continue to pump
asset prices
and say to everyone what do you mean you
gotta vote for me i'm making you rich
right asset prices are going up but the
long-term impact of this as we know
is the bottom fifty percent of americans
get absolutely crushed
by this type of manipulation when you
flood the market with trillions of
dollars
you cannot believe that you are not
going to devalue the dollar
and when you devalue the dollar 45 of
americans don't own a single stock
50 percent of americans cannot come up
with a 400
emergency payment so all they do is they
live paycheck to paycheck and 100 of
their wealth is sitting in cash
and you are going to absolutely ravage
their net worth
their savings and you are not only going
to hurt what they already have saved the
little bit that they have in terms of
sitting in cash
and take away that purchasing power but
on top of that
you are also going to make it so they
can make less money right one of the
hidden thefts everyone knows is
inflation in terms of eating at your
cash savings but a second hidden theft
is the fact that all of these people who
are getting paid hourly wages people in
hospitality
uh service industries et cetera they may
get paid 12
an hour and they think they're getting
paid the same amount of money year in
and year out because they keep getting
paid 12
an hour but when you print this much
money the purchasing power of that 12
goes away and so they're actually making
less money per hour
plus you're eating away at their savings
you are going to completely
decimate the bottom 50 of americans
and you are going to extend and
accelerate the
widening inequality gap right if you
look at the pandemic
who's made money billionaires in the
united states have made
hundreds of billions of dollars during
this
why because the government is bailing
out
corporations the whole key to money
and wealth is to not hold cash
you have to get out of cash you have to
get into asset prices
don't fight the fed don't believe that
the fed cares about the little guy
the fed cares about managing an economy
and pushing asset prices if you go and
you look at
the stock market and you zoom out over
the last 30 40 50 years
and you zoom out it looks like a 45
degree angle
sure there's volatility in there it's a
45 degree angle up into the right
why because structurally stock prices
are going up over long periods of time
with nothing to do with the underlying
companies it has
everything to do with the fact that the
dollar the denominator the thing that
the asset is denominated in is being
devalued
many people will say you're crazy well
am i if you take that same stock market
and you denominate it in
gold the stock market is down since
1971.
so the stocks actually have not
increased in value
if you denominate in gold but if you
denominate in dollars it looks like a
45 degree up into the right there is a
devaluation of currency the whole secret
to building wealth is to get out of cash
and get into assets that are denominated
in dollars
they will continue to go up in value
over long periods of time stocks
real estate gold bitcoin all this stuff
the dollar is being devalued
and so that's what we're seeing happen
here the problem is that
50 of americans the bottom 50 percent
they don't have financial education
the system is built based on the idea
that 50
of people don't understand how money
works they don't understand how the
economy works and so they get hurt while
the rich get richer
and so what i believe is likely to occur
if we were to see unemployment benefits
go out
and not be uh renewed or extended if we
were to see
pvp get expire have all of the
businesses fire those employees and no
more stimulus come
if you thought that the civil rights and
the individual liberties and personal
freedom
um and the racism and the police
brutality those protests
were bad imagine when people say i don't
have
money on top of all of those things
right there will be incredible unrest
and so this is a thing where
i just don't see us getting to uh in an
election year getting to november
without
any sort of uh continued uh monetary
stimulus in the market
so i'm gonna keep going for about two or
three minutes uh if you can
um take all of your questions put them
in here i'll go back and i'll try to
answer as many as i can i'll hang out
for about 30 minutes or so
but one last thing i want to say before
uh i start answering questions is
i personally believe that the most
important thing people can do right now
is understand
that the recession is not over right we
are only four or five months into this
thing
and so there's all sorts of chaos that
is still on the horizon
and that may happen in the next three or
four months if they let all the monetary
stimulus expire
or they can extend it even further but
there's no way
that this is over in the sense that all
of the economic
uh situation is resolved what we are
getting is we are getting
tricked by looking at stock prices into
thinking things are okay
but the economic data is really bad so
i'll leave you with a story before i
start answering these questions which is
yesterday i went and i had lunch um at a
place in new york city right it's a
little small hole in the wall place
the small business owner restaurant
owner he is the owner of the restaurant
he helps to serve the food along with a
couple of employees he's also the cook
he's from spain he has a number of
businesses in spain but he also owns a
restaurant here in the united states he
lives here
he traditionally goes back to spain
every quarter but because of all of the
issues he
he hasn't been back obviously this year
and so i was sitting there eating lunch
with paulina and i said to him i said
hey man how's it going
i see him every day right and he looked
at me and he goes
i used to serve 80 tables every day for
lunch he's right around near the u.n
building there's a bunch of office
buildings all of those people used to
come into his restaurant he used to have
a line outside
80 tables that he would do every single
lunch
today he is averaging six six
tables that is what he's averaging
it is a complete decimation of his
business more than 90
loss in terms of the customer base on a
daily basis
that guy is struggling and if this goes
on for too long
that man will not make it his business
will not make it
and so i still believe 20 to 25
of small businesses in america
unfortunately are not going to make it
they're not going to make it out the
other side and if that occurs
small businesses are responsible for 50
percent of jobs in america
if 20 to 25 percent of businesses went
away in the small business sector
that means 10 give or take of american
jobs would disappear
through this it would take us a decade
or more
to get back to having that type of job
growth
and so the damage and the long-term
scarring that we are likely to have from
this cannot be overstated
right it you have to understand we are
still in a recession
do not get tricked by the monetary
stimulus do not buy into
the high that we are getting from that
it is still
incredible economic carnage on the small
business level even at large
corporations
right and so this is likely to continue
for a long period of time
so be patient and make sure you are
prepared
all right i am going to go all the way
back and start answering questions
fire as many of them as you can here um
before i start this
please remember to uh like the video
there's a little thumbs up button
punch that so more people can watch this
and then also make sure you're
subscribed to the channel so when i do
these
you get a notification
all right let's see uh bitcoin let's
just get bitcoin out of the way
so bitcoin's doing exactly what i would
expect it to do
right earlier this year um everyone was
yelling and screaming and saying wait a
second
bitcoin should thrive in this situation
but as i've explained many times
there was a liquidity crisis no matter
what the asset is
the asset is going to sell off if
there's a liquid market so investors are
sitting there they say i'm scared
it's uncertain future i need cash i'm
going to sell anything i have in my
portfolio that has a market attached to
it and they dump it with such
aggressiveness that the prices drop
because there's such an overwhelming of
sellers in the market
and so you saw stocks go down you saw
gold go down you saw bitcoin go down
everything went down correlations trend
towards one during a liquidity crisis
go back to 2008 2009 gold went down
almost 30
during 2008 the summer of 2008 during
the liquidity crisis and then once the
fed started to pump you saw this massive
rally
almost 200 percent increase in the price
of gold hit an all-time high in 2011.
i think that's exactly what's happening
here is you saw all the asset prices
dropped down
then all of a sudden the fed stepped in
they started to pump asset prices you've
seen stocks explode gold explode bitcoin
explode et cetera
the key though is bitcoin is going to be
the fastest horse in the in the words of
paul tudor jones right that's why he put
two percent of his net worth
or of his assets into uh bitcoin it's
because
bitcoin's the most volatile out of them
the way volatility works is
it works against you on the way down
right
hyper volatile dropped 50 in a single
day during the
uh the kind of deep liquidity crisis it
went down over 30 percent
but on the way up the volatility works
for you and so what you've seen is
bitcoin today is up like 30 35
on the year so year to date bitcoin is
up 30 to 35
gold is up i think like 15 to 20 uh last
numbers i saw and then stocks are about
flat
so you're going to see kind of the most
volatile assets perform the best on the
way up i think over the next two to
three years bitcoin will be the out
performer
uh in terms of all asset classes uh or
asset prices so
i i'm not worried about kind of where
bitcoin is right now it's actually
pretty encouraging to see where it is
especially with the having just occurred
i continue to think that when you have a
supply
shock like that combined with a demand
shock that we're seeing
you're going to have this like rocket
fuel over the next 18 months for the
price of bitcoin
um uh let's see here
uh invest in china so china's a really
interesting one to me
uh for a couple of different reasons one
you have incredible geopolitical risk
right now right
uh everyone has seen the conversation
around tiktok for example so that's one
of the companies that's kind of
getting caught in all the geopolitical
and economic war with china
you also see kind of the hong kong um
you know
debacle that's occurring where literally
china has essentially taken the
sovereignty
of uh hong kong away they've taken the
freedoms of the hong kong people
um and so china to me there is a strong
argument for the demographics for the
consumerism
uh kind of for all of the uh uh
population
size right all of that stuff there's a
very strong argument but there is
incredible risk on the geopolitical side
on the economic side in terms of
sanctions all that kind of stuff and
then also
you essentially you have comments you
have the communist party
in china who is likely to do things that
are just off the wall
right what they did in hong kong was off
the wall i don't think anyone realized
that that was going to happen
right before it happened so when you see
that type of stuff
you then say to yourself it would be a
pretty big risk to go invest in a place
with so much uncertainty
and also so much manipulation that can
occur right if you look at something
like luck and coffee for example
complete fraud all of a sudden it just
blows up and everyone's looking around
saying wait what just happened
well it was a fraud so how much of the
actual economic activity in china is
real it's up for debate
the other thing that i will say is if
you listen to somebody like a peter
zahan peter zahan believes that
china as it stands today will not be
around in a decade
it's a pretty aggressive statement right
i don't know if i necessarily agree with
that level of severity but he believes
that there will just be too much
infighting and too much
social instability and therefore it will
lead up to kind of a breaking up of
hong kong era of china uh as a single
kind of unified country
we'll see i do think though that peter
is correct in that the demographics of
the united states are one of the most
attractive anywhere in the world
uh yes we are seeing incredible um
kind of uh federal spending to help our
elderly so for those that don't know
the u.s government has collected more
federal tax income or revenue for the
government
every year for the last six fiscal years
so if you go all the way back
for the last six years the government
continues to get
more and more federal income revenue why
then does the deficit on an annual basis
so not the total deficit we're over 6 26
trillion dollars
on that deficit side but every single
year the deficit we're running
is getting larger and larger wait a
second how is that how is it the
government's taking in more revenue
yet the deficit is getting larger and
larger well it's because
we continue to spend way more than we
should
40 of government spending goes to people
over the age of 65.
40 of our spending goes to people over
the age of 65.
that is only going to accelerate there's
estimations by the end of the 2020s
the 50 of the federal government
spending is going to go to people over
the age of 65.
and so that is a thing when you look at
you say demographically
that's kind of concerning but also when
you look at other demographics in terms
of the median age
and stuff like that the us is actually
one of the best places in in the world
places like nigeria in the uh african
continent other
um kind of attractive demographics as
well so i think that you've got to just
be very very careful in somewhere like
china
the united states is kind of uh where i
focus a lot of my time on
but i do think that there will be other
places in the world you just got to look
at demographics and kind of understand
the geopolitical situation
uh that's going on uh what are the
questions that we have here um
i'm seeing a lot of construction
activity in the south lots of deals
particularly in opportunity zones yeah
look
there's no secret that when cheap
capital floods the market there's going
to be tons of building and there's going
to be tons of
construction and home purchases now one
thing that i will
kind of separate here is you can't just
paint the same brush across the united
states in the real estate market so take
a place like new york city right now
new york city is actually seeing the
median price fall
for apartments and also it is seeing an
incredible surplus of supply while that
demand drops
now two factors are a play one there's a
pandemic obviously and so there's a lot
of people looking around saying why do i
live in new york i should just move out
if i don't have new york as a city there
then really all i do is i have an
overpriced apartment with not a lot of
space
so you see people kind of leaving of
course that's going to have a
impact on prices prices are going to
come down because there's going to be
less demand
the second thing you'll see in that a
more structural kind of longer term
trend is
in the called 2010 11 12 13 14 15 16
maybe even in the 17
there was this massive rise right really
to kind of 15 or 16
massive rise of foreign money flooding
into the market
and so people from asia especially china
were coming in they were just
you know throwing money around they were
buying up apartments some for investment
properties
some a store of value uh some were doing
it today she wanted to live there some
were buying it so their kids could live
there
whatever the reason was there was
massive influx of money from asia
and foreign investors well developers
and builders saw this and said wait a
second let's build a bunch more homes we
can make a ton of money look at all this
money that's flooding the market
there is a lag time in terms of the idea
of i should build a building
to actually being able to sell it called
18 24 sometimes 36 months
well as they started to build all of a
sudden we then saw a peak of that
foreign investment and started to drop
off so now you have all of this in um
inventory that's coming online but that
demand's not there and so you have this
massive surplus that's where you get
the median prices coming down and you
get kind of uh not a lot of liquidity in
the real estate market in new york city
is because demand has disappeared and
there's that surplus in terms of
inventory that is not true in other
areas so in the major metros that may be
true because that's where most of the
foreign investment was going
but areas like the southwest for example
um in the southeast across the the
midwest
uh you still see incredible demand
because cheap capital is flooding the
market there's a bunch of migration
trends that are working for you as well
so it doesn't surprise me that uh
construction is uh kind of restarting as
economies reopen like i said earlier
june saw 17 increase um
in in construction so uh
let's see here can you talk about what
you think happens with the elections it
seems like whatever the outcome is
violence protests will be the response
from the losing group
so i'm i'm not necessarily concerned
that there will be
violence um there's definitely gonna be
protests if you remember when trump was
elected there was protest
uh but what i do think is really
important here is
um i come from a position that all
politicians are the same and before
everyone gets upset about that what i
will say
is the political position of president
is near impossible job right you
basically go in
wide-eyed bushy-tailed with all these
ideas and you're gonna make all this
change
and then you get in you realize that the
bureaucracies and the mechanisms of the
checks and balances of the government
make it really hard to get things done
and so there are um there are two things
that you cannot argue about our last two
presidents
president obama got a lot of things done
you can argue the merits of whether they
were good or bad but he got a lot of
things done
donald trump has actually gotten a lot
of things done you can argue the merits
of
good or bad but again both presidents
have got a lot of things done and so
they've chosen to take a position of
executive orders and kind of i'm going
to dictate this to the government and
then have the government respond with
checks and balances things like that
now what i do believe is an entire
generation of people
are growing up and they're realizing no
one is coming to save me
there is no president doesn't matter who
the president is joe biden or
uh donald trump it doesn't matter i have
to look out for myself no one is going
to look out for me
the way i look out for myself and so i
think that's going to change a lot of
the way that people think about politics
i think it's also going to change the
way that people kind of acted both as an
investor as an entrepreneur or as an
employee at a business
so with that said if you look at what
donald trump's
basically saying is he's going out and
he's saying hey look i'm going to
continue to remove
regulation i'm going to continue to
drive uh taxes
uh being taken away right and kind of
get money into uh
people's accounts i'm going to kind of
hang my hat on the stock market going up
all of these economic things that's a
very kind of conservative or
republican-driven
narrative on the other side you have joe
biden saying uh literally he's going to
create this massive tax plan right he's
going to increase taxes
kind of all that kind of stuff again
neither one of these
is the right solution and here's why i
don't believe
that the government is a good allocator
of capital they're actually a
horrible allocator of capital and so if
you look at what
an entire generation of people just saw
the federal reserve
went into their bank account right the
federal reserve balance sheet and they
edited the number
they were on 60 minutes bragging about
the fact that they have unlimited
liquidity
unlimited money and so if you can go
into your bank account you can just edit
how much money you have
why do you need my money for taxes why
do you need to take money from my
business
or from my employees or my friends and
my family if you can just
edit your bank account why do you need
my money i can't edit my bank account
but you can
and so i think that's what we're
starting to see is people are waking up
and saying wait a second
this is a racket right i i've always
said that the virus is exposing this
uh the shams in society which is the
federal reserve doesn't need our money
they can create more of it
and they're financially incentivized to
create more of it the about the federal
reserve's balance sheet has increased by
75 over the last couple of months
75 they increased it trillions of
dollars almost three
or over three trillion dollars they
expanded their balance sheet by
why do they need our money they have
their own money they can create money
they have the ultimate power i think
there's entire generation that's waking
up to that and they're going to start
writing off a lot of these politicians
and saying listen it doesn't matter what
your plan is i got to look out for
myself
i also think that there is a very
serious popularity contest going on in
politics now
where uh it would not surprise me it
says a million times uh
the rock i believe at some point will
run um and it would not surprise me
over 20 to 25 years i think it will take
20 25 years but at some point we will
see kim kardashian
um take an attempt at running uh i
actually think that both of those people
have a shot of getting a nomination i
don't know if they actually have a shot
of winning the presidency
but given where we are in politics today
in terms of
this popularity contest they're two of
the most recognizable figures in
in the world not even america in the
world uh and so i think both of them
uh would have a shot at winning the
nomination not saying that they should
get the nomination not saying that they
even would be good
uh candidates or good presidents but i
do think that that's kind of
structurally where we are
in american politics now um i said over
and over again
whether people like it or not whether i
like it or not i think that donald trump
wins in an absolute landslide
uh in november and you kind of have two
uh forces at play here
one he has the position of power in the
sense that he's able to manipulate the
economy
and continue to do things to make it
look like he has everything under
control
uh and essentially he can make everybody
who uh is in the wealthy and elite class
he can make everybody more wealthy
between now and november that's why you
can continue to see stock prices going
up and all this kind of stuff and cheap
capital
flooding the market that ends up being a
plus in the category or in the bucket
for the incumbent
uh and then also i i just don't think
that uh joe biden is necessarily the
strongest candidate that could have been
put forward again
doesn't mean that he couldn't do a good
job as a president but when you look at
kind of the field of candidates
i think there's a lot of americans
whether right or wrong who are saying
look
we basically have 270 plus year olds who
are running for president
like if i gotta pick one or the other
like the guy who is gonna make me rich
rather than take more taxes from me
i'm gonna go with him that's my my
opinion on it
uh again i am uh him the ultimate
independent which is
uh i frankly think that the two party
political system is really stupid so
we'll see what happens but that's enough
about politics um
there's an old saying there's nothing
more permanent than a temporary
government measure
could not agree with this more my whole
argument in terms of
ubi for example i do think that we will
see ubi at some point the next five six
years in the united states
uh it wouldn't surprise me to see it
coming out of this crisis
uh once it gets started they'll never be
able to take it away so if you see them
go ahead and announce hey rather than a
one-time stimulus check
we're actually going to do a monthly
check whether that's 500 bucks a
thousand bucks 2 000
whatever it is they won't be able to
take it away political suicide for any
politician who implements ubi
uh for a future politician to try to
take it away from people
they feel like that is there right now
they feel like you're taking away
government benefits
uh and so once we get there i think that
it's gonna be pretty crazy
um so in terms of uh
tesla i see a bunch of people asking me
about tesla i think tesla is really
interesting
uh for three reasons one the market
whether you agree with it or not
has proven one side of that argument
correct and i put it in air quotes in
the sense of
uh if you were a short tesla at 200 300
400
what you realize is that even if you
believe you're still right
the market can remain irrational longer
than you can stay in salt
or that you can stay solvent and so you
just saw you know from 200
it was trading at 1600 the other day it
went up 8x
so whether you think you're right or not
the market just disproved your theory
that the stock was going to go down
doesn't mean that you're not right in
terms of the company the financials
whatever
but you were betting on as a short
seller that the stock price was going to
go down and went up 8x you were wrong
now what that brings in the question is
okay what happens
next and so there's two schools of
thought here there are a lot of people
who
invest in the public markets and they
look at things and they say hey i'm
going to look at the financials of a
business
i'm going to make investment decisions
based on those financials and kind of
short-term price movements i believe
that
tesla at 1500 is going to go up or down
in price i'm going to make investments
based on that
there's another group of people people
who i look into right i don't invest in
the public markets but the way i look at
investing in companies and if i was a
public market investor i would look at
something like tesla is i would say two
things
do i believe that electric cars are
going to become more valuable and gain
market share in the future or do i think
they're going to gain less
i think that at some point in the future
electric cars are going to be the market
so you're going to see gasoline-powered
cars go away i don't know if it takes 10
15 20 years
but electric cars will be the standard
in the future okay so you have a
trend which tesla would benefit from
they have wind at their back
the second thing i would say is is tesla
the best electric car maker
on the market yes hands down no no
question about it
and so if you have a trend of an
industry where it is going to go from a
small market share today of car sales or
electric
to the dominant or the standard of the
majority then obviously you would want
to okay who's the leader in that
industry
tesla i think that tesla will be worth
more money in the future
meaning you know five 10 15 years from
today than it is today
now what happens between now and 15
years there'll be incredible volatility
right go back to amazon stock amazon
stock since it went public over 20 years
every single year has had a double-digit
drawdown in the stock price
the intra-year average of that drawdown
is over 30
so if you held amazon stock from the ipo
to today every year it's dropped 30
on average right at one point i dropped
90 but because
innovation it drives volatility right
and volatility goes hand in hand with
innovation
it was such an innovative company that
you got all of this crazy volatility but
if you held the entire way it's one of
the best performing stocks that
uh we've seen in the last 20 years tesla
is likely to do the same thing
it's super volatile of course it's a
highly innovative disruptive business
if it ends up being successful right and
he does make it 15 years
my guess is that it is going to be the
leader in electric vehicles and it'll
continue to gain value
if you want to bet on short-term price
movements and that's your game you think
you have an advantage there knock
yourself out
if you want to bet on long-term trends
and your long-term holder and you're not
going to you know trade and all that
stuff
then hey that's your thing too but like
you've got to separate this idea of
short sellers versus long-term investors
and ultimately the market is the the
referee there and so far
the short sellers were disproven um
doesn't mean that they can't be right in
the future
but so far the market has said that
those that were long tesla
have been correct and those that were
the short sellers were wrong um
let's see here what else do we have uh
trusting billionaires um all right
that's a great one so somebody said the
only billionaire they trust is peter
thiel
um look at the end of the day uh when
you look at the billionaires in america
uh yes there are plenty of them that
inherited their wealth
but the majority of people who are
first-time billionaires in their family
they are some of the most innovative
intelligent creative people
in the world right and so i personally
believe
that we should encourage as many
billionaires in the world as possible
if there's 400 or 500 billionaires in
the united states we should hope that
there's 5 000 billionaires in the united
states
because what that means is that we are
leaving the world and innovation
and creativity in production right and
manufacturing all this kind of stuff
like
being a billionaire means that you
created a billion dollars or more of
value in the world now you can argue
whether that's a good thing a bad thing
whatever
but at the end of the day that's how you
become a billionaire you
created value and you captured that
value how you did it is up for debate
whatever but we should want as many
billionaires in the world as possible
i actually hope that every single person
there's a thousand people watching this
right now i hope you guys are all
billionaires
right and by the way if you can't be a
billionaire then being a sent a
millionaire would be awesome right a
hundred plus million dollars and if you
can't do that then become a millionaire
or if you can't do that become a hundred
thousand here right
like we should want to see people become
successful and what i hope
occurs is that we can get into a world
where one there's this feeling of hey i
want to give back
and so you see things like the giving
pledge where people give away 99 of
their wealth
right they spend a lot of time employing
uh people all that kind of stuff
but also too is we can change the
structure of how the system works
and that to me is why i'm so excited
about bitcoin right is you don't have to
be in this inflationary system where
people
end up getting screwed by the system
they end up getting a situation where
they can't get ahead
but at the end of the day we should want
as many billionaires in the world as
possible
and we should also want to see every
single person succeed but you've got to
have a system that sets up
for people to do that are there bad
people as billionaires of course
are there good people as billionaires of
course i don't think being a billionaire
makes you good or bad it's kind of like
what do you do with the power and
responsibility once you get it
um let's see here uh ubi will unleash
creativity and innovation as people are
no longer living hand-to-mouth it's a
minimum stipend not an invitation to
stay on the couch
uh from ben yeah look again ubi is a
highly controversial topic uh
the short answer is we don't know what
ubi will do right there's not enough
data to understand the impacts of ubi
i am not here to debate the merits of it
it's more of i just think it's going to
happen
right whether we like it or not and they
may call it ubi they may call it modern
monetary theory they may call it
you know money raining from the sky like
it doesn't matter what nomenclature you
put on
it's just the fact that the government
is incentivized to continue to
give um you know benefits and money to
people and i think that's what's gonna
happen
and so uh how people use that is a
whole nother uh situation uh peter
schiff
um look the gold community uh as i said
before
the gold investors have been right in
terms of the structural issues with the
economy that you know peter schiff a lot
of people give him a hard time
uh in the crypto community but peter was
right about the 2008 crisis
he's been right about a lot of the
structural issues in the economy uh
we agree meaning me and him we agree on
i don't know
75 80 of the things he says like all the
issues that he identifies absolutely
for sure i actually agree with him that
gold uh will benefit from the economic
situation that we're in we've seen gold
go up it's gone up more than stocks for
example
um and if there continues to be high
levels of inflation uh gold will
continue to uh to benefit there as well
i just personally think that bitcoin
will benefit
more than gold so it's not to me a
binary thing gold versus bitcoin it's
just that bitcoin is going to outperform
gold but gold will still do well so
peter and i are absolutely fine we talk
you know every once in a while and i i
tend to think that he's a
he's a good dude and look he likes to
troll people on the internet fine
whatever have a blast he's having fun
and people troll him back so like you
know he's kind of engaging and you guys
are just doing what he wants you to do
now one thing on inflation that i will
say i don't know if a lot of people saw
marty bent wrote about this this week um
that i thought was really interesting
is if i remember correctly i think it's
the st louis fed chair may have been
boston i i can't remember
but somebody at one of the federal
reserves said that they're not worried
about inflation they actually think that
we should hit the two percent inflation
uh and potentially overshoot our two
percent inflation target before we start
worrying about inflation
rewind that here what i just said they
were talking about
inflation and because we were printing
trillions of dollars they were
essentially asked like are you worried
about inflation
j powell said i'm not worried about
inflation worry about that down the road
this person said we shouldn't worry
about it we should at least
hit our two percent inflation target and
potentially
overshoot it when i hear inflation
what i hear is we are going to steal the
wealth of the bottom 50 of americans
that's what it's current and we can talk
about how it pumps asset prices and does
all this stuff and it's supposed to spur
economic activity
all that other stuff is fine but when i
hear that we're gonna overshoot two
percent inflation
that's the cpi metric remember coming
out of 2008 2009 crisis
we never saw the high three four percent
inflation that everyone thought we were
going to see in the cpi metrics
but if you go and you actually look at
inflation you say wait a second
everyone's inflation
level that they experience is not the
same so one person may be experiencing
1.5
inflation another socio-economic class
may be experiencing six percent
inflation
there's a number of studies that have
come out of both the united states and
uh
europe that show that actually some
people coming out of 2008 2009
crisis had six to ten percent inflation
but that's not what the the narrative is
the cpi metric doesn't say that but
again if you don't have
all of your wealth in cash and you're
not living paycheck to paycheck and you
have an inflation-adjusted wage contract
of course the inflation that you
experience is going to be much lower
than the person who isn't protected by
an inflation-adjusted wage contract
doesn't have any assets and is living
paycheck to paycheck with 100 of the
wealth and cash
so when i hear that they want to
overshoot
the two percent inflation target
one that means that they are actually
going to be aggressive enough to hit it
this time or they they want to be
so we're going to have more stimulus on
the way we're going to continue to
devalue the dollar
and that means that the people at the
lowest end of the socio-economic ladder
they're going to experience double-digit
inflation
double digit inflation what is the
difference between us and lebanon
austin venezuela we may not hit true
hyperinflation
but if you're living in a world where
you experience 10 or more inflation
and you literally feel like you can't
get ahead you're getting paid in cash
and you're watching your
uh wealth be devalued what's the
difference there's not that much
difference in lebanon right now
85 percent lost in the value of the
currency against the dollar
and then when people see that their
their currency is being devalued
most people don't understand economics
they don't understand how money works
they don't understand what's going on
all they know is that price of bread
just doubled
overnight or in a week or two weeks why
is the bread twice as expensive as it
was yesterday
was because my currency buys less of it
and so what do they say well get me out
of the currency no-brainer
but they go to the bank and the bank
says hey you can't withdraw more than x
or x of your local currency there's a
capital control you can only take out so
much
and by the way you have to pull it out
in our currency you can't pull it out in
u.s dollars or any other foreign
currency you have to pull it you're
locked into our currency
so what it does is it creates this
massive black market bitcoin selling at
2x the value of bitcoin
elsewhere right or or people wanting to
get dollars and all this kind of stuff
and so what you see is all that the
currency
drives social unrest they literally were
lighting banks on fire
in lebanon why because
they were trapped in a currency and the
people at the lowest end of the
socio-economic ladder got hurt the worst
now that's the 85 drop in value of the
currency i don't think we're gonna see
that in the u.s dollar but i do think
we're going to see high levels of
inflation for the lowest socioeconomic
classes
i do think it will lead to social unrest
at some point and i do believe
that we are going to see an ever
widening inequality gap that is going to
go on steroids if you look back since
1971
it basically looks like this right it's
like 45 degree angles to the
uh up and 45 degree and goes down for
the poor so rich get richer pouring it
poor
i do believe that we are going to see
that massively increase
you cannot print trillions of dollars
and not expect an impact on the back end
it's just not possible
so we'll see what happens there um could
you please comment on the merits of
printing money how will those work with
cryptocurrency yeah so
for those that have never heard this
i'll take two seconds on uh why i am so
bullish on bitcoin
right i believe there's two financial
systems uh there's the legacy financial
system it's inflationary the
cur the core unit of account or the
global reserve currency is the us dollar
i think there's a second alternative
financial system uh basically think of
this as the internet economy
right that is a digital decentralized
financial system the core unit of
account there is bitcoin
if you look at what is going to occur in
the legacy world every single currency
in the world is going to get digitized
we will have a digital dollar we will
have a digital euro digital we want a
digital yen
right we will have private currency so
you'll see things like libra and other
companies launching these private
digital currencies
and then you have something like bitcoin
and so when you get in a world where
every single
currency is digitized now what you do is
you get a competition at the monetary
policy level because if you're in
lebanon or venezuela or zimbabwe or
in other places in the world when you
get locked in capital controls and
people say hey you can't get out
of your local currency you then go and
you look for dollars but the black
market is dangerous
right in terms of one you can get ripped
off into it's actually violent two
is if you end up getting dollars and you
put in your bank account the bank could
seize that money or your government
could seize that money
and three is you could go into things
like gold for example but it's super
hard right it's not portable it's not
divisible it's hard to buy things with
all that kind of stuff
and so what ends up happening now is you
say what money can i get on the internet
i have an internet connection this is
2020. like how do i get
my wealth out of my local currency into
something else and so if every currency
is digitized i now can buy just with an
internet connection i can buy dollars
i can buy one i can buy euros i can buy
all this stuff so you get
every single currency is now accessible
to me right that's in a steady state
when anything's digitized
as we move towards that world if only
the digital one or the digital yen is
available
or you know digital rmb euro whatever
and the us dollar is not digitized
then actually people have better access
to other foreign currencies than the us
dollar would be a huge problem for the
us so i think we should run
and get a digital dollar as soon as
possible but once everything's digitized
you then have a competition not at the
technology layer you have a competition
at the monetary policy layer
and i believe that both individuals and
governments individuals
and governments are going to believe
that
every single currency is being
manipulated in the world the us dollar
the
uh all the way down the right euro rmb
everything so
when you believe that everything is
being digitized or is being manipulated
you say well which one's not being
manipulated oh there's this currency
that has a monetary policy that's
programmatic
transparent and it is completely out of
the control of
anybody else it's a fully decentralized
system
i trust that system because i at least
know what's going on and i know i'm not
getting screwed
if you look at countries if all of a
sudden russia and china said hey we want
to
start to transact in another currency
but what they see is
wait russia is manipulating their
currency china's manipulating their
currency
we don't want to use the dollar because
it's a
an expensive tough system for us to use
instead what they're going to start to
say at some point we will see countries
say well why don't we use this other
currency that's decentralized
that's transparent that's programmable
that nobody owns we know nobody's
manipulating that one let's settle our
transaction in a currency where no one
has manipulation powers
and so i think that it is an
inevitability that bitcoin will rise to
become the global reserve currency
individuals and governments will see
that it is complete game theory the
second that one country says we're going
to put it in our
reserves um in our uh national reserves
or says we're going to adopt it there
will be a global fomo and every country
will rush in
because there's only 21 million bitcoin
that scarcity will drive immense value
i think that everyone is actually
drastically underestimating the
potential of bitcoin
it is a market expanding technology
meaning that uh most people compared to
couldn't capture the gold market can it
capture the global monetary supply
market gold's
seven eight trillion dollars global
monetary supplies 80 90 trillion dollars
i actually think bitcoin can capture
upwards of
120 100 350 maybe even 200 trillion
dollars
of total adjustable uh market how do
they do that
most people are incentivized to get out
of their local currency like we talked
about with inflation get into stocks
real estate
are you know gold bitcoin whatever so
they get out of their currency into
these store value assets
if all of a sudden you have a currency
though that is a store of value right it
doesn't devalue over time it actually
increases in value over time because
it is a artificial cap supply you're
gonna steal market share back from those
assets
into the monetary supply and so i think
that you could see something like a
doubling of the global monetary supply
with bitcoin capturing majority of the
market
uh over a long period of time again
could take 20 30 years i just think
that's the inevitability that we're
gonna see
so we'll see what happens there um
let's see here uh
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna hang out
for 10 more minutes so get me all your
questions
and uh i will um answer as many of them
as i can
uh oh before i forget
if you want to hear more of this
uh please please please go
and sign up i write a letter
every single morning to 50 000 literally
over 50 000 people read this every
single day please i just put it in the
uh in the chat
go sign up um and uh and you'll get kind
of my thoughts on all this stuff every
single day
um remember to like the video please
subscribe to the channel all that stuff
um covid yeah so look i i think that
one of the things on covet that's really
important here is um
it's serious right we are seeing an
explosion now one of the things that
i've continued to say from day one is
there is a complete lack of math and
science in this country
like there is absolute absurdity going
on i have heard of things like
if people die but tested positive for
covid they count as a code to death
right literally no somebody i know a
family member of theirs died
from cancer and they had tested positive
for covid and when they looked at the
paper
it said covet death and the whole family
was like what do you mean it's a covet
death like they obviously died from
cancer like we know
we know like they've been suffering from
cancer this entire time
but the hospital has a financial
incentive to market as a coveted death
so there is a complete um kind of
manipulation of numbers going on on one
side
on the other side right so that was kind
of the anti uh coveted numbers argument
the pro covid number argument is that
there is a comp
uh rise in many places so new york city
for example there's a rise
in the number of deaths that are
uncategorized and so there's a lot of
people saying well
what else could that be people aren't
getting car accidents all this kind of
stuff right
so my point is not are the numbers
under counting or overcounting my point
is that we don't know and i'll take it
to this
uh to this so i saw yesterday a report
that said the cdc is now reporting
record numbers
of of covid cases right everyone's
freaking out
but then it said actually one of the
things that is happening is that
some of the states are counting they're
double counting
if you test positive through the the
traditional test
and then you get an antibody test and
you test positive that counts as two
covid cases
so they're double counting people in
other situations
they're counting the antibody test as a
positive case
but just because you have the antibodies
doesn't mean that you actually have a
hospitalization
or you're showing symptoms or anything
like that and so again
there's a lack of math and science
there's a lack of intellectual
rigor right i have yet to see mainstream
media question the numbers
complete lack of intellectual rigor
going on looking at this we're just
taking the numbers that were being given
and we're saying sure they're okay
you can't do that because we can't make
good decisions with bad data so i think
that we have to get a
a kind of reckoning there again i don't
know what the numbers are
right i don't know if we're over
counting or under counting what i do
know is we're your damn mask
it's not that hard i love what the
georgia governor is doing the georgia
governor said right this is this is like
the epitome of threading the needle
in terms of covet the atlanta mayor got
covet and started to mandate like she
personally got coveted
she began to mandate legally manned it
you had to wear a mask
and the governor sued her so the the
mayor is
uh uh democrat the governor is
republican
the governor sued the mayor of atlanta
and said you cannot
force people to wear a mess you cannot
legally mandate it right you are
violating their constitutional rights so
you sued the mayor to stop it
but then he went on television and urged
people to wear masks
so what i took away from that is he's
not anti-mask
he's pro mask pro constitution he's
saying we can't legally require people
to do this
but we can strongly urge people we can
educate them we can get them
uh understanding what the impact of that
is etc again is that the right answer i
don't know
but i do think that that's a very
nuanced way to look at this
where you can be pro-constitution and
pro-mast
pro-science again are there better
solutions sure there's all kinds of
things that we can be doing but i think
that we've gotten into a world where
there's
the mob comes after people right the
mainstream media
like many people may have seen barry
weiss she quit the new york times andrew
sullivan
uh just quit uh new york mag and vox
media and what they're basically saying
is like look
i can no longer say the things that i
believe
because the mob comes after me and i was
reading andrew sullivan for those of you
that haven't read it i highly suggest
going and reading his uh piece
he basically said uh see you friday i
think or something if you just type in
andrew sullivan
see you friday uh you'll find his piece
and he said look
in my newsroom everyone hates me and
they feel uncomfortable around me
because of my conservative views they
put it in uh
in um air like you know i'm putting in
air quotes but he said my conservative
views are
i didn't want trump as president i came
out as openly gay i fought for
you know all of these social things he's
basically saying look like i'm a
democrat
but he's like but it's gotten to the
point where i'm considered a threat
because i violate the narrative because
i'm willing to
talk about things that i don't even
necessarily agree i'm willing to have
kind of intellectual rigor and
independent thought and so i think that
that is one of the things that we've got
to get back to in the
in this country is we've got to start to
seek truth
over consensus who cares what the
consensus
is just because it's the consensus does
not mean it's right
we have to find truth that coveted cases
true we got to find the truth what is
the number how many people are dying we
got to have good data to make good
decisions
in the economic world we have to find
truth what is the economic reality on
the ground who cares what the consensus
is what is the truth
in the social issues what is the truth
who cares what the consensus is
the truth has to reign supreme in our
society
because the day you give up truth and
you start to
kind of optimize for consensus is the
day that we lose our way
and so that is true across all you know
walks of life
and even in your personal life and so i
think that's the biggest thing right now
that i'm paying attention to is
where are the independent thinkers and
again the independent thinkers isn't
this like weird world of oh independent
thinkers don't believe in coronavirus or
mass
actually most of the independent
thinkers believe in masks right if you
look at most people
uh in silicon valley who are kind of
think from first principles and have
independent thought and are
you know kind of constantly contrarian
they were some of the first people
saying hey kovind's real this is serious
we should go into lockdown and kind of
got made fun of for it
so i think that again we have to just
get into this world where we seek truth
over consensus
i think the economic situation that
we're facing today uh is much much worse
than people are realizing we're kind of
uh there's this mirage of the stock
prices are going up everyone's making
money in the top fifty percent of
americans
while the bottom fifty percent of
americans are getting absolutely ravaged
and i think that there's gonna be a
reckoning in terms of either we're gonna
have tons more stimulus in order to
continue to kind of bridge us to an
economic recovery
or you're going to see the stimulus
expire and you're going to have to see a
market correction in order to kind of
meet economic reality
but we must seek truth over consensus it
is absolutely
essential all right that's it
please like the video 100 hour and 15
minutes or so
like the video please subscribe to the
channel go
tweet the link let's get as many people
watching this as possible i'll start
trying to do these more often if people
are going to show up and watch them
if you guys share them and you know kind
of gets the views that uh
that um tell me it's worth the time i
will absolutely come and do it more
often than these
if you want like i said let me put this
in here one more time
every day i write a letter it is my
personal opinion
on all sorts of different ideas um in
terms of business technology
economics bitcoin whatever click on that
link
sign up for the email and i will talk to
you guys later i hope every single one
of you has a great weekend please stay
safe continue to be kind to your friends
and we will talk
soon